You see in the history of magic, what
30, 35 years, they weren't able to make
a lot of interesting colorless
commanders and that's not exactly on
them. I mean, colorless, it wasn't even
supposed to be a thing and it's just
difficult. It's either Eldrazi or big
artifacts, that's it. They've tried
other themes, but clearly these are not
meant to lead a deck. We just don't have
enough tools to work with. Now, with
Marvel, it brought us a lot of legends
and I was pretty hyped cuz I've always
wanted a colorless deck and and you
know, with characters like Voltron,
Vision, Galactus, I thought maybe they
would be able to figure out something
interesting. But, again, disappointed.
Uh they either do big mana or artifacts,
but there are better commanders for
these. Or when it's interesting, there's
no support. So, I looked away, but that
was until my friend Vu reminded me that
the Fantastic Car can be a commander.
And a few hours later, it's turning out
to be the most interesting colorless
commander I've seen in years. It is
unique, fun, aggressive, can be pretty
strong, and actually is on a really
reasonable budget for a colorless deck.
Yeah, this. I'm not joking. Okay, quick
self-introduction. This is Jin with Next
Level Commander and my goal is to make
decks that are unique, but also
functional. Marvel did bring us quite a
few pretty interesting options and I
have a few deck tech videos lined up.
So, if you're interested, please like
and subscribe. Anyways, back to our
vehicle commander. Three mana 4/4
vehicle with no crew cost. It turns into
a creature when you play any
non-creature spell. That seems
reasonable, but that's not why we're
here. We are here for the last ability.
When we cast our fourth non-creature
spell each turn, we can sacrifice
Fantastic Car and if we do, it turns
into four 4/4 tokens with flying and
haste. At first, it seemed pretty good
in other formats, maybe even busted, but
in EDH, it's a lot of work to make 16
damage. Now, Vu did mention that you can
play a bunch of zero cost artifacts to
power out the split ability very early
on, but then what? I mean, if you're in
blue, sure, but in colorless, you just
spent four cards to make four 4/4s and
and that's your entire game. You're not
going to have reliable card draw. So,
basically, we need ramp, card draw, and
being able to reliably pump out the 16
power early because every time we wait
it becomes less relevant. So, it's a
cool concept, but we needed something we
needed a glue that holds everything
together. I was just about to give up,
but like one of those very realistic
detective shows I got inspiration from
real life when I was eating instant
noodles saving money for the new set
really missing the days before magic
when I was able to just order pizza. And
actually, I got married recently and
just as I was sorting out the
invitations figuring out who not to
invite a gleam of sunlight refracted
through my window and I found the
[music] line. And no, this time we are
not digging through the bulk bin. I'm
going straight for the dumpster behind
my LGS. The Robin, the pizza, the
Lembas, some light energy thingies, a
snow globe, and all that this makes the
body of our deck. Drawing a card and
bringing in an artifact for some other
synergies and interactions is nice.
Although, I would much prefer the ones
that are cheap and sacrifice for cards,
but there are just not that many. So, we
have to make do with the two mana ones.
Now, the problem with these is they are
a little bit expensive. Casting four of
these a turn is eight mana, so we need
some cost reducers. And unfortunately,
we also don't have a ton of those in
colorless, so we are playing them all.
Cloudkey, Foundry Inspector, Joyous
Familiar, and Semblance Anvil. It does
cost me a card, but the reduction is
massive. And also, of course, Ugin. Now,
Glaring Fleshraker isn't exactly a cost
reducer, but it has a very similar
function and sometimes even better if
your hand has a few zero cost artifacts.
Also, with the number of artifacts we're
playing, the damage ability can be very
relevant. Now, these are some of the
most important cards in the deck. If you
get one of these cheap ones in the
opening hand, your game will go really
well. We actually don't have a lot of
ramp in this deck because a lot of them
are not that efficient. We want the ones
that can chain into each other. So,
something like War and Powerstone
doesn't work that well with what we're
doing. On the other hand, these zero
mana ones are really good cuz in a pinch
you can drop them for nothing to fill in
for that fourth non-creature spell.
Aside from that, the deck is still kind
of short on gas, so we want these mana
rocks that can draw us cards, especially
this one here. Spoiler alert, we have
almost 40 differently named lands in the
deck. Yeah, this goes crazy. And
meanwhile, another really interesting
inclusion, Coveted Jewel. Honestly, this
is too risky to include in most decks,
but here we do have some artifact
synergies, specifically Scepter of the
Dragon our opponents from trying to take
it. But even if we don't, with the
attackers we have, there are scenarios
where we wouldn't mind doing some back
and forth with this with an opponent or
every opponent. And a few more pieces of
less reliable ramp, we have Clock of
Omens, The Ironworks, and Radiant Lotus.
Now, these are all here to capitalize on
the fact that we probably will have a
lot of artifacts doing nothing on our
board. Okay, and those are the ramp
options. Now, we look at some other
utility like card draw and recursion is
difficult, but we have to try to keep
the gas flowing. Got to be creative
here. We have a lot of fodder artifacts,
so Trading Post seems great here. And
with all the sacrificing, cards like
Scrap Trawler is pretty good. And Mystic
Forge plus any cost reducer, we can get
some massive value. Now, we are drawing
a lot of cards, but we're not going up
on cards because we're can-tripping
basically. But a Hammer of Purphoros
breaks that balance. It's expensive, but
with that on the board, everything
becomes value. And one of my favorite
draw spells in colorless, Sensei's
Divining Top. This is three mana less
than Kozilek, but can often draw us more
than four cards. I do want to talk about
Skullclamp. It is not at its best in
this deck because we don't have a lot of
things to sacrifice. And And if we're
really struggling for cards, I guess we
can clamp a 4/4 token and sack that, but
we don't want to. We want to attack.
Although, one interesting interaction is
that with our commander, it first turns
into a creature. So, if we have one mana
to spare, we can clamp the fantastic
card and then cast the fourth spell. The
card sacrifices itself, we get four
tokens, and two cards. Feels good when
it happens. And finally, this is
something I don't usually use, but yeah,
we are pretty desperate, Pendant of
Prosperity. If you play it right, it's
broken. Just give it to someone who's
behind on mana or the draw-go player who
always has mana open or that one person
who's the greediest in your group, you
know who it is. Doesn't work that well
in our group cuz that person is me. But
yeah, that's our card advantage suite.
Now, for some removals and answers,
Ugin's are always nutty but the new Ugin
is specifically bonkers in our deck.
With the zero ability to add three mana,
we can easily cast three to four other
spells after Ugin to exile four to five
permanents and even more later on. Then
we have the typical All Is Dust and
Oblivion Stone in case things get scary
out there. And kind of random, but
Metalwork Colossus is mostly a Timmy
card I want to play but usually it's
pretty cheap sometimes free and in the
graveyard is another cycle. That wraps
up our non-land cards. Now for lands,
the first thing I want to mention is I'm
trying to play 39 lands and and maybe it
should be more. The reason for that is
because we are trying to get a very
consistent and explosive start. We want
to be attacking with those four tokens
by turn four the latest. And for that
reason, we are a bit more reliant on
mulligans. And that can easily backfire
if we don't have enough lands. And we
have a ton of utility cuz we don't need
colored fixing and also because wastes
are expensive. We've got the Urza
package, the Locus package, and the
speed package. I mean, they're kind of
useful. The best ones of course are
these ones that interact with artifacts.
Also these ones that can draw us cards
when we're desperate or very desperate.
Also just a Haven of the Spirit Dragon
cuz Ugin's are some of the best cards in
the deck. In terms of play experience,
the deck is trying to be explosive but
it's not that fast. I mean, if we get a
sweet hand, we can get the four tokens
on turn three but usually it's turn
four. And there's a decent chance that
we get another set on turn five. That's
pretty good, right? We are not the most
resilient deck. Artifacts are brittle.
We're trying really hard to keep the gas
flowing but being colorless, yeah, we
will run out. And there will come a
point in the game where flying hasty
cards just isn't that relevant even if
it's four of them. Also, if our opponent
really wants to, they can disrupt our
plan pretty easily just in response to
the fourth spell, destroy the commander,
and yeah, and we have to go again. And
the deck I find is actually fairly
difficult to play, specifically the
first four to five turns. You know,
figuring out the sequencing, planning
for that one big turn with four spells.
Do we cast a cantrip now or do we hold
it for later? Lots to figure out and
it's very easy to mess up. Now for
budget, I managed to keep it at $200,
which is pretty difficult for colorless.
It can usually go really high, and this
deck also can benefit if you're willing
to splurge. I mean, a One Ring, of
course, would really help, but just the
acceleration options, even just better
utility lands, for example, this one
from Marty's Vault, is really good in
artifact decks. And in colorless, we do
have to nickel and dime for value, and
sometimes overpay for them. For bracket,
I think this will do fine in bracket two
or bracket three. In bracket two, it
might be a little bit too fast
sometimes. Like, people will see you
get, "Oh, 16 power on turn four, that's
kind of scary." But, that's also
basically our peak. So, where this deck
lands kind of depends on how you manage
your game and other people's
perceptions. But, yeah, what draws me to
this deck is how aggressive it is, how
different it is than the other colorless
decks I've seen. And they tried making
aggressive colorless commanders, but
those just don't work, and this one
does. All right, that's all we have.
Thank you for watching my video. This is
Jin with Next Level Commander, and I'll
see you in the next video.